I've got a transformation t-that's a
mapping from RN to RN it can be
represented by the matrix a so the
transformation of X is equal to a times
X we saw in the last video it's
interesting to find the vectors that
only get scaled up or down by the
transformation so we're interested in
the vectors where I take the
transformation of some special vector V
and equals of course a times V and we
say it only gets scaled up by some
factor lambda times V and these are
interesting because they make for
interesting basis vectors that you know
the transformation matrix and the
alternate basis this is one of the basis
vectors might be easier to compute might
be for good coordinate systems but
they're in general interesting and we
call vectors V that satisfy this we call
them I ghen vectors eigen vectors and we
call their scaling factors the eigen
values eigen values associated with this
transformation and that eigen vector and
we you know hopefully from that last
video we have a little bit of
appreciation of why they're useful but
now in this video let's at least try to
determine what some of them are you know
basically what we know so far if you
show me an eigen vector I can I can
verify that it definitely is the case or
an eigen value I could verify the case
but I don't know how to matic way of
solving for either of them so let's see
if we can come up with something so in
general we're looking for solutions to
the equation a times a times V is equal
to lambda V it's equal to lambda times
the vector now one solution might
immediately pop at you pop out it U and
that's just B is equal to the zero
vector and that definitely is a solution
although it's not normally considered to
be an eigenvector just because one it
doesn't it's not a useful basis vector
it doesn't add anything to a basis it
doesn't you know add really the amount
of vectors that you can span when you
throw the basis vector in there and also
it's not clear what is your eigen value
that's associated with it because if V
is equal to 0 any eigen value will work
for that so normally when we're looking
for eigen vectors we start with the
assumption that we're looking for
our nonzero vectors so we're looking for
vectors that are not equal to the zero
vector so given that let's see if we can
play around with this equation a little
bit and see if we can at least come up
with eigen values maybe in this video so
we subtract AV from both sides we get
the zero vector is equal to lambda V
minus a times V now we can rewrite we
can rewrite V as V is just the same
thing as the identity matrix times V
right V is a member of RN the identity
matrix n by n you just multiply we're
just going to get V again so if I
rewrite V this way at least on this part
of the expression let me swap sides so
then I'll get lambda times set of V I'll
write the identity matrix the N by n
identity matrix times V minus a times V
is equal to the zero vector now I have
one matrix times V minus another matrix
times V matrix vector products they have
the distributive property so this is
equivalent to the matrix lambda times
the identity matrix minus a times the
vector V and that's going to be equal to
zero right this is just some matrix
right here some matrix and the whole
reason why I made the substitution is so
that I could write this as a matrix
vector product instead of just a scalar
vector product and that way I was able
to essentially factor out the V and just
write this whole equation as essentially
some matrix vector product is equal to 0
now in order if we assume that this is
the case and we're assuming remember
we're assuming that V does not equal to
0 so what does this mean
so we know that V we know that V is a
member of the null space of this matrix
right here let me write this down V is a
member of the null space of lambda I sub
n minus a I know that might look a
little convoluted to you right now but
just you know imagine this is
sub-matrix B it might make it simpler
this is just some matrix here right
that's B let's make that substitution
then this equation just becomes B V is
equal to zero now if we want to look at
the null space of this the null space of
B the null space of B is all of the
vectors X that are a member of RN such
that B times X is equal to zero well V
is clearly one of those guys right
because B times V is equal to zero we
just came we're assuming B salt V solves
this equation that gets us all the way
to the assumption that B must solve this
equation and V is not equal to zero so V
is a member of the null space and this
is a non-trivial member of the null
space we already said that the zero
vector is always going to be a member of
the null space and it would make this
true but we're assuming V is nonzero
we're only interested in nonzero eigen
vectors and that means that this guy's
null space has to be non-trivial so this
means that the null space of lambda I n
minus a is non-trivial non-trivial the
zero vector is the only is not the only
member you might remember before that
the only time the only time we write
this in general if I have some matrix I
don't have all used a and B let's say I
have some matrix D D is DS these columns
these columns are linearly independent
if and only if the null space of the
null space of D the null space of D only
contains the zero vector right so if we
have some matrix here whose null space
does not only contain the zero vector
then it has linearly dependent columns
it has linearly dependent columns so we
know that and I just wrote that there to
kind of show you what we do know and the
fact that this one doesn't have a
trivial null space tells us that we're
dealing with linearly dependent columns
so lambda I n minus a it looks all fancy
but this is just a matrix must have
linearly dependent columns or another
way to say that is you know if you have
linearly dependent columns you're not
invertible you're not invertible which
also means that your determinant must be
equal to zero all of these are true if
your determinant is equal to zero you're
not going to be invertible you're not
you're gonna have linearly dependent
columns if your determinant is equal to
zero then that also means that you have
non-trivial non-trivial
members in your null space and so if
your determinant is equal to zero that
means there's some lambdas there's some
lambdas for which this is true for non
zero vectors V so if there are some
solutions if there are some non-zero
vector V s that satisfy this equation
then then this matrix right here must
have must have must have a determinant
of 0 and it goes the other way if this
guy has a determinant of 0 then there
must be or if there's some lambdas that
make this guy have a determinant of 0
then those lambdas are going to satisfy
this equation and you can go the other
way if there's some land doesn't satisfy
this and those lambdas are going to make
this matrix have a 0 determinant so the
determinant let me write this so if and
only if so I'll let me write this a a v
is equal to lambda V for non non zero V
for non zero V's if and only if and only
if and only if the determinant the
determinant of lambda I n minus a is
equal to the zero vector is equal to no
not the zero vector sorry it's just
equal to 0 the determinant is just a
scalar factor and so that's our big
takeaway note we're saying now how is
that useful for me Sal you know we did
all of this manipulation I talked a
little bit about the null spaces and my
big takeaway
is that in order for this to be true for
some nonzero vectors V then lambda has
to be some value such that if I take the
determinant of lambda times the identity
matrix minus a it has got to be equal to
zero and the reason why this is useful
is that you can actually set this
equation up for your matrices and then
solve for your lambdas and we're going
to do that in the next video